les schémas tati pour préparer le
mariage de ma cousine
nous sommes dans la commune de saint
pierre dans le sud de l'île dans le fond
de cette cour des femmes s'affairent à
la préparation d'une fête
le lendemain c'est jour de mariage là on
prépare le tool pour le mariage on hamm
est brute de manioc ou dans le feu là
les formes il pourrait par les gâteaux
grandes ou petites
ancien ou jeunes les petites mains tout
knicks rap et prépare ingrédients pâte
pour les gâteaux beignets et décoration
pour la grande fête et ce avec le
sourire et dans la bonne humeur
et au milieu de cette cuisine à ciel
ouvert deux jeunes femmes préparent ce
que les mahorais appelle le mti nano une
préparation cosmétiques qu'elle applique
sur leur visage toujours les lots les
femmes elles m6 a acquis mais on l'avait
par le m sinda nous en grand comoriens
ou un petit anneau en maori ou masque de
beauté est une parure cosmétiques
traditionnels portés par les femmes
on la retrouve aussi dans certaines
cultures est africaine comme comores ou
mozambique
ce masque constitue d'une pâte à base de
santal et porté en public s'il est comme
pour les masques de beauté vendus en
occident destiné à améliorer l'état de
l'épiderme
il est également destiné à protéger la
peau des agressions du soleil et des
insectes lors des activités journalières
comme la cuisine ou les travaux
agricoles
de surcroît il est considéré comme un
cosmétique à part entière salut toi le
visage ou parfois ya le soleil nous en
est les mahorais ou pour protéger le
soleil pour avoir la bo 12 dose blais
eurostar la pâte que l'on applique sur
le visage est obtenu grâce à une pierre
en corail et d'un morceau de bois de
santal que l'on frotte par des
mouvements circulaires avec les deux
mains en y versant un peu d'eau mais en
fonction de la couleur et du soin que
l'on veut apporter au visage
il existe plusieurs mois a frotté le
roseau mais pour avoir la beauté pour
leur beauté pour que voilà et le blanc
au nez parce qu'ils sont parfumés faire
ça valorise la vma éléments mais voilà
et les jeunes c'est pareil
les jeunes en mai par lionel richard
héroux l'orb lewenza nous est un masque
qui purifie les peaux acnéiques et
aident à éliminer les boutons beaucoup
de femmes d'hommes avec ce masque sans
aucune contre indication connus mais les
raisons pour porter ce masque ne sont
pas seulement cosmétique mais aussi
esthétiques comme l'expliqué mathy qui
compare le mca noah du rouge à lèvres
ses comptes emails rouge à lèvres c'est
comme tu mets maquillage c'est quand tu
mets injures comme ça nous ces masses
qui maquillage pour est et infâme être
belle
la pole visage parce que parfois tu as
laitages parfois cas le bouton ça lève
tout
une parure qui a selon hématies un vrai
pouvoir de séduction de deux jeunes
filles qu'il croiserait dans la rue les
jeunes gens maoré seraient attirés par
celles qui portent le masque garde le
premier qui avait le masque
voilà parce qu'ils gagnent toujours elle
est la lie le masque toujours le masque
et les jolies elles qui est commun et
les couleurs commun toujours s'il a mis
un truc dans le visage c'est le premier
qui est là il resta a dépassé par tout
le monde mais la plupart ya les gens qui
adorent le voir le funky message si dans
notre culture occidentale les masques ne
sont pas portés mais appliquée en toute
discrétion le soir le mti nanou lui se
porte comme une parure un maquillage de
jour comme de nuit
un atout pour les femmes à aures qui
veulent plaire tout en couleurs et en
prime toujours avec le sourire et dans
la bonne humeur